JOEL SCHINDALL:
Initially, the course
was taught in a more or less
conventional manner where
Blade and I did the
teaching, and we
had one teaching assistant
who was actually someone
that Blade new from
Tufts University who
came in and helped
the students with some
of the technical issues
in the design problems.
But after the first term,
some of the students
volunteered to be teaching
assistants the following term.
And they brought a
whole new dimension
to the teaching of the
course, because the students
were encouraged to--
The students don't do their
homework during class,
they do it typically at
10:00 PM or 2:00 AM or 4:00
AM, any time of
the day or night.
And it's frustrating
to run into an obstacle
and not be able to get an
answer to your question.
So we established a website
where the students can go to it
and ask their question.
And we have three or
four teaching assistants
who are monitoring
that website 24/7.
Literally 24/7.
And it's fun to watch the
dialogue because you'll
often-- at 2:00 AM a
question will come in.
One of the students
will say, well, Jim
is best equipped to
answer this question,
but he's sleeping now.
I'm going to give you
an initial answer.
And about 5:00 or 6:00
in the morning, Jim
will get back on and give
you the rest of the answer.
We have probably,
over the course
of the term, at least 1,000
question-answer exchanges that
take place.
The students who
evaluate the course
often give perfect
scores of seven
to the teaching assistants.
A little bit humbling for
us and the faculty who
are getting good
scores-- 6.1, 6.2--
but the teaching assistants
get the best scores
because they're
actually one-on-one
guiding the students
through a problem.
And they're doing it very much
from the student's perspective,
because this is the
same problem that they
had to deal with
the previous year
so they know what
questions to ask.
They phrase their
answers so eloquently.
You know, today's
younger generation
is accustomed to electronic
tools, to chatting, you know,
to social media, and they have
a very nice deferential and yet
effective style of interacting
with this communication.